software gore
what are we going to do about this as
programmers
we see these memes are people making fun
of us
they think this is funny i am kidding
this is a real thing and i want to
address it here in this video
i am a software developer and apparently
also now a video
editing specialist that's what people
seem to know me for
although i'm definitely not that
anyway there's a lot of buzz recently
about the state of software engineering
and that it might be
in a state of decline and all the
software gore we see
these memes might seem a little bit
funny to some people
and you know they are humorous at times
but
how does this happen and that's what i
want to talk about
and how we can fix it and maybe what we
can all do to try to make this
problem start to dwindle and
maybe we can improve the state of
software engineering
one small step at a time
but first let's just let's just check
out some memes
ohio will be eliminated i am human
incorrect please try again play black
mesa or
play black mesa it's a real head
scratcher there
not not sure which one to pick uh
what's this one could not copy files
because no
because no dudes are quite hilarious
peppa pig
infamous world war ii death factory
comes to life
step inside the experience in horror for
yourself
peppa pig you got dark
please wait while one note inserts the d
okay i gotta stop i think you get it
sometimes they're funny but also
sometimes they're very dangerous
we've known software to cause
some serious accidents
about a year ago
there was a pretty bad accident where a
plane went down because of a system
not controlling its angle this isn't the
one this is just the article
oh wait yeah this is the one
see this was published may 7 2019 on the
claims journal
and it talks about how a sensor
basically failed to
do the right thing it all came back to
whoever engineered the software
things were overlooked and a plane went
down and people died
this was software gore but it turned
into real core
and it's really tragic and that sort of
thing
really hits her home to a software
developer
when you think you might be working on
autonomous things one day you never know
really i just want to do games because
they're relatively
safe and you don't have to worry about
too much uh the gore staying is like
contained within that unless your cd
projekt red and you just
want to release a game way too early and
destroy your own company that's kind of
a different story
yeah i'm sure everybody knows what i'm
talking about
i recently watched this talk by jonathan
blow
called preventing the collapse of
civilization
that he did quite a while ago about a
year ago and
i guess it was two years ago um well
he brings up basically software gore and
this
this thing this uh talk and
his big thesis is that all
technologies at some point become lost
or forgotten over time
and the expertise of how it was once
done is lost over time
knowledge is not often transferred to
the next generation
and all these great things we have are
buried as a relic of the past and
become lost so that's that's the whole
thesis of this talk
and he relates it to software and that
this could happen the software and based
on sort of the state of things
compared to how like precise all the the
og
guys who made linux and stuff originally
and who uh you know pioneered all this
all the software and stuff
we're we're in a state where we kind of
just hack things
together that are pieces of
things that are already built or
something along those lines so
a lot of the programmers these days
don't really know what goes on beyond
goes on behind the scenes and they're
just kind of using
tools to build things but if they didn't
have those tools they wouldn't be able
to do much
because they don't know how memory works
they don't know how computers work so
they don't uh understand how electricity
flows through the
the components of a computer and all
that stuff
so i'm sure i could say it much more
eloquently but i think you probably get
the point here
and the point i'm getting to because i
don't want to make this super long but i
want to i do want to drop some
references
jonathan below in this talk leaves a lot
of great references
uh for more things you can watch about
this sort of dystopian
software gore and our civilization and
software going downhill but i don't want
that to happen as you may have guessed
since i have this channel called
codetech tutorials which is all about
simplifying and making the stuff as
simple as possible basically it
and it's not only that
it kind of you know yeah subscribe
please subscribe i know like only five
percent of you that watch or subscribe
so please help me get that number a
little higher that would be amazing
um a lot of people that watch my channel
watch it because they want to learn
something
and
and what i want to do is try to bridge
that gap for a lot of people now i know
i won't be able to help everybody or
some people might just be
way beyond my level and not need my you
know whatever there's always a case
where
um i don't know what i'm saying
basically
the point is i'm trying to do something
to help but also i'm documenting my
experience
as you might know i have a degree in
computer science just
a bachelor's and wow it was more of just
something i needed to do to to make sure
i had the core knowledge because i was
kind of coming into this
you know you know i would just look
things up online all the time try to
figure stuff out but
you don't really know what you're
missing until it's put in front of you
sometimes i know that sounds weird but
that's kind of one of the biggest things
about school or going through
any course really is
it gets you branching out into areas
so but schools are notoriously becoming
worse and worse these days unfortunately
uh you know your results may vary i'm
sure there are still
tons of really great schools out there
don't get me wrong but there are also
some that are
for lack of a better word a scam to just
get your college money
and give you some sort of degree sort of
thing
so what can we do to prevent this well i
think the biggest
and best thing we can do is share our
knowledge and keep things as open source
as possible
so one of the biggest issues seems to be
when the old guy that knew how to do
everything retires there's nobody
to fill his spot so all these newcomers
come in
and for some reason they can't
get this knowledge and i was wondering
why is that
couldn't they just ask him shouldn't he
have understudies if he's been doing
this for so long
he should definitely have some people
under his belt that he's like you know
training and stuff that's
how it's always worked at any place i've
ever worked basically is
yeah you bring the new guys in have them
get mentored and that's you know that's
their initial
starting period is them being mentored
some and seeing if they can kind of
start to grasp this stuff
and uh so i guess that doesn't always
happen
now in the past you can imagine why that
didn't happen like way in the past when
civilizations collapsed and you know
they lost all the technology of the
ancient
egyptians and stuff now i'm no historian
but i'm just kind of riffing
because that sort of thing did happen
it's it's easier to imagine because they
didn't have
cars and internet and paper and printers
uh they were you know stamping things in
their tablets or
like clay tablets not computer tablets
like actual rock and carving into rock
and stuff
we don't have to deal with that anymore
everything's available
so to completely disagree with
jonathan blow i don't think software's
in decline i think it's actually quite
going in the opposite direction a lot of
people are able to get
a lot of this old knowledge that was
really hard to discover before
now thanks to the internet and all this
easy research we can do all day
it's it's a lot easier so why are we
seeing more software core well i think i
know
but before we continue let me just take
this code i don't understand and throw
it into the bin of doom
so the hypothesis i have for you is that
there are just a ton of software
developers these days there used to not
be
very many so here's a report from this
dax website
about number of software developers 2018
about 24 million 2019
20 about 26 and a half and then
by 2023 it's projected there'll be
another million
so it looks like we're gaining i don't
know we'll say approximately
a million and a half every year new
developers
uh or or just total number so some might
be retiring and leaving this like i'm
guessing i don't know how they pull
their statistics i guess they have some
things about it here so i assume they're
semi-correct but basically as these new
software developers start and get hired
they make mistakes that's that's
probably the biggest thing now it
should be up to you know someone with
some experience to oversee all this and
not let the mistakes come to
the light or go out in the world but it
happens and
yeah with so many new people joining
you're gonna see some of these mistakes
it's inevitable it happens you know so
it's it's kind of a lull of odds
so we're in the past there were very few
developers and
very few pieces of software really so
when software was made it was
it was uh tested you know by the rest of
the people in your field
uh presumably and
they'd be uh pretty good at sorting it
out and sorting out
all the different options there weren't
as many options now software comes with
packages extensions and all sorts of
things and all that needs to play nicely
and it's hard to get everything tested
so
i think that's the reason why is just
because there's so much more software
and so many new developers
that we're just seeing
you know maybe a slightly higher percent
of bad software
but also you know just with so much
software we're gonna see
more bad software in general
hope that makes sense it makes sense in
my head but i feel like i explained it
weirdly
so casey moriotti who you might know
from
the the programming he does live all the
time with uh
i can't handmade hero that's what it is
he did he did like a lecture called
the 30 million lion problem and if you
haven't watched it you should definitely
check it out
but one of the things he states in it is
uh that
software now is just layered on top of
other software
when so when you have one underlying
piece go wrong
it makes the stuff that you are
presumably doing correctly
go wrong because something underneath it
did so you don't have access to all this
underlying stuff you know there's
a lot of different levels of languages
from machine code assembly to
c and up so if you're using something
that's way on top of all that and
someone
made a mistake way back in the c code
you don't have any control over that
because you're using an over
over arching layer so that's that's one
of the
one of the big points he makes here and
with so many lines of code
and so many things you're not even aware
of happening anymore it just becomes
like
too much and there's just bound to be
errors
so he kind of points that out and it
does make sense
there's obviously a lot more to the talk
but i thought it was really interesting
problems just become exponential after
all or
after a while if you just keep layering
this software and
and just things underneath that you're
not really sure how they work but they
do
i come across this a lot myself little
incidents here and there every day
sometimes it's just googling stuff
so it's often said that big institutions
eventually will fail to upkeep their
software for some reason and i'm not
really sure why that is but it does seem
to be true
we've seen that very recently with cd
projekt red
who have made just tons of amazing games
but in this last one have just
completely missed the mark um
well i don't want to say completely
that's a whole nother subject on its own
but basically
i'm i'm going to listen to the depths
forget what everyone else says
about uh cyberpunk 2077
the bottom line is this and i heard it
directly from one of the devs on the
inside team that was working on the game
i don't know where it was on some
youtube video in an interview basically
he said
the game will be ready in 2021 that's
how it was projected
that's how everything looked from the
inside and that was how it was in the
devs
minds because of just the general scope
of things so
my point is don't play the game until
about a year from now so in 2022
basically
pick up cyberpunk then it'll be good
because it'll actually be finished right
now it is not a finished game
and uh just the absolute oversight and
marketing it so hard and putting all
that pressure into marketing
and just leaving uh the devs
in in the dirt like that that was wrong
that was really wrong that's a really
dirty move i can't imagine anybody ever
working for
cd projekt red or just like going in
there like oh i can work for this
company
it's like one they're going to be
blacklisted by devs unless they really
actually get this straightened out
from a leadership perspective you know
and it's not about overworking the devs
it's about
just managing the project correctly
hilarious situation so anyway the point
i was getting to is uh
google too google's starting to see this
a lot their software is getting worse
and worse a lot of people complain about
gmail
sure they usually eventually fix it but
i see this with search results now and
there's no way to like do anything about
it because like i was just
one day looking at opengl unload
textures and objects
seems like a pretty straightforward
thing and you know google should be able
to get you right to that but no
no look at this top link do you see the
date on this
you really think this is the best result
google
this is like the biggest joke of a
search result ever
so this this just them giving me an
article that's
13 years old about it about a technology
it's like it's like if you looked up
news about the iphone
and they started telling you about the
iphone 2 as the top link
you know that that's what this is like
this is this is abysmal
and there's nothing i can do about it i
can't say
uh this is irrelevant now this no longer
makes sense
and it doesn't this is like i did look
through this it's completely useless
information these days there's nothing
here
that's any good for opengl or unloading
textures or objects or anything this is
just completely
useless link so i looked at the next one
about the same completely useless
completely most these are just
completely useless finally
the third one takes you to the actual
documentation
of how to do this stuff so this was like
the first actual useful link but these
first two are just so
far off they're not even close to the
mark if they were close to the mark i
could give them a little credit
but these are just like uh they're just
so far off
it blows my mind that this comment of
like a search and a technology and a
thing
shouldn't google have a little bit of
insight is to not give you an old
article
so it's just kind of a real world
example that i
ran into recently about the software
gore stuff
and the potential decline from these big
companies
so what can we do about it that's that's
the big question
uh and the only thing really is is we
can learn from each other and we can
teach each other and we can make open
source stuff
and we can leave comments about
actual proper links and scientific
documentation and how things actually
work and things you need to know for
little specific
incidents basically we have to make sure
we transfer all this knowledge we know
because if we if one of us gets one of
us developers that knows like
things that hardly anybody else knows
because we've been studying our
butts off for years what happens if we
get hit by a bus tomorrow and we never
get to transfer this knowledge
what have we been working for you know
start writing stuff
start documenting start making videos
that's how we prevent the software gore
that's how we
prevent the collapse
i don't know that it just felt like i
had to say something dramatic there
that's going to do it for this video
thank you to all my viewers and all you
guys
and i'm going to leave some links down
below if you want to show me
further support or anything please feel
free to leave a comment and help me get
a higher subscriber count than five six
percent please that would be awesome
love you guys matt from codetech
tutorials over and out
peace